a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also download
our free printable 30-day minimalism
game calendar
over at theminimalists.com
i still have broken things i hope to fix
keychain stickers
in a set of drawers used to store
knickknacks birthday cards pictures
wait broken birthday cards uh i've been
meaning to
clear it so i can get rid of the drawers
all together oh i see
okay so and then the drawers used to
store these nick max birthday
cards and i thought i thought she was
talking about broken drawers and anyway
um yeah i think there are all these
i don't like for mariah and i it's uh we
get all these christmas cards
thank you so much for adding to these
christmas cards
but it's like we have this stack of
christmas cards where i'm like we got to
throw these out
of course and mariah's like well you
know it's nice to see the families as if
i'm like it is
but like they're literally like what are
we gonna do like hang on to them until
we get the next christmas cards or
you know yeah it's funny how those
things stack up and
karen sounds like she has a lot of these
uh
little things that stack up the word
that stood out to me is fix
right i have so many broken things i
hope to fix this actually came up quite
a few times uh
we deleted several of them here but like
that that term
fix came up a lot like i have broken
things
that i'm hoping to fix that's a
pathology i think
that i that i certainly embody i'm a
fixer
right i want to fix things
there is no fixed though it's always
changing
and what has changed now is you have a
broken bunch of broken things that are
no longer adding value to your life
and so i'm not telling you to do this
but if it's me
what i would do is simply have a
deadline if i don't fix this by
the end of the year the end of the month
the end of the week whatever it might be
then it's probably not worth holding on
to
once i once i've established that
deadline that makes sense
to me i i don't know i think like i'm
trying to think the last thing that i
threw away
that i was thinking about fixing i just
know that like there are have
been things that come up with like oh i
could fix that but like
there's a truth that i can get to very
quickly
am i going to fix this or is it going to
sit around there isn't there's not even
a deadline it's like i can be honest
with myself
uh if i am going to fix it then it gets
fixed right away
yeah it's like if i have a like my
mountain bike i don't ride it every
single day
yeah but uh you know every
i walked out and the tire was flat and i
was like oh i need to pump it up
so i pump it up
and then it turns out somehow it had
busted i don't know how the tube busted
just sitting on my balcony
uh so i was like oh i got to fix that
tire i fixed it right away right it
wasn't like oh put that off until
tomorrow like if something needs fixed
then i have a plan to fix it right away
there's never like a plan
to plan to fix it yeah yeah i would i
would
you know me because of the ocd like i i
would do something very similar although
i would probably schedule the fixing of
it
it's like oh on thursday at 3 p.m you
have house cleaning on your calendar
yeah yeah
time to tidy it's tidy up tuesdays
patent pending